- TURN TO THE RIGHT.
EYES FORWARD.
- GOOD AFTERNOON, GENTLEMEN.
I'M WARDEN SMALLS.
- [stifles laugh]
- ELECTRIC CHAIR!
[electricity crackles]
ANYWAY, I RUN A FAIR AND
HONORABLE CHRISTIAN PRISON HERE.
RULE NUMBER ONE--
NO SARCASM.
- [sarcastically]
AW, THAT'S A GREAT RULE.
- WELL, LOOKS LIKE WE GOT US
A REBEL HERE.
TRY THIS ON FOR SIZE.
- OW!
WHY'D YOU HIT ME?
- BECAUSE AS THE BIBLE SAYS,
IT'S MUCH MORE PAINFUL
TO WATCH YOUR FRIEND SUFFER
FOR YOUR SINS.
- [sarcastically]
OH, YEAH, IT IS.
- THAT SOUNDS LIKE
MORE SARCASM, BOY.
- UNH!
- [sarcastically]
OH, NO, PLEASE, STOP.
- I'LL BREAK YOU
OF THAT SARCASM, SON,
IF I HAVE TO BREAK EVERY BILLY
CLUB OVER YOUR FRIEND'S HEAD.
- OW! HEY!
AH, STOP! OH!
GOD DAMN!
[sarcastically]
UM, HEY, WARDEN,
THAT'S A REALLY NICE TIE.
TAKE THAT, MALLOY!
OW!
WAIT, WAIT, WAIT!
I THOUGHT MY FRIEND
HAD TO SUFFER FOR MY SINS.
- I WAS BEING SARCASTIC,
IDIOT!
WELCOME
TO HAZELHURST PRISON.
I GUARANTEE YOU BOYS
GONNA STAY IN LINE,
OR MY NAME ISN'T
WARDEN TINY SMALLS.
- [stifles laugh]
- ELECTRIC CHAIR!
[electricity crackling]
- SCARE ME STRAIGHT, HUH?
GOOD PLAN, WOODY.
WHEN WE GET HOME, I'M GONNA
SPANK THE SHIT OUT OF YOU!
- YOU'RE NOT GOING HOME,
MALLOY.
YOU'RE STAYING HERE
UNTIL YOU'VE LEARNED A LESSON.
- OH, YOU'RE GETTING
AN ANGRY SPANKING NOW!
GET ME OUT OF HERE, WOODY.
- WELL, I--NO!
NO, I MADE MY DECISION,
AND I'M STICKING TO IT!
GOOD-BYE, MALLOY!
BE STRONG, PAPA BEAR.
[sniffles]
DON'T LOOK BACK.
IT'S CALLED TOUGH LOVE.
[crying]
- OH, WHAT THE--
WHAT THE HELL'S WRONG WITH YOU?
LEAVE ME ALONE!